welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's keynote presentation
cannabis for Health Promotion and
disease prevention it is presented by
dr. Dustin Sulak integrative osteopathic
physician the founder and medical
director of Integrative Health and
co-founder of healer calm my name is
Judy O'Rourke and I'll be your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots laberd's is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. su lac I will
now turn this presentation over to him
all right thank you for having me I am
feeling a lot of gratitude in this
moment for the opportunity to get this
information into the hands of people who
are interested in promoting health and
preventing disease and interested in
learning more about what cannabis has to
offer us so let's dig in here's an
overview of what we'll cover during my
talk it's cannabis for health promotion
and disease prevention we'll look at
sleep coronary artery disease stroke
cancer obesity and diabetes and then at
the end of the presentation I'll get
into the
twofold nuts and bolts of how I think
people can use cannabis to promote
health and then outside of cannabis
other dietary and lifestyle approaches
to enhancing the activity of our
endocannabinoid system because we can do
that with cannabis but we can do it with
other interventions as well
there are today's learning objectives so
number one is describe the rates of
several public health outcomes such as
diabetes and obesity in cannabis users
versus non users understand the
preclinical findings on cannabinoids and
brain injury and heart disease and how
this information may translate to
real-life scenarios and describe health
promoting activities that can enhance
the function of the endocannabinoids
system so let's take a moment to
consider why prevention why is
prevention an important topic in the
world of cannabis and in the world of
healthcare in general so as a clinician
I've been practicing for about 10 years
and generally attracting patients who
have failed to respond to conventional
treatments from all walks of life and
many different areas of medicine I see
patients with cancer neurologic
conditions infectious conditions
psychiatric conditions and they
typically come to me after nothing else
has worked and impressively and I don't
take credit for this I mostly credit
cannabis because it's such a safe and
effective medicine but I get great
results with some of the toughest
patients in medicine and so I started
thinking if I can get such good results
with some of the toughest cases could I
used a similar intervention in a
different way to prevent disease could I
would it be possible to keep people
healthy and not have to go through all
the work of getting sick and then trying
to work our way back to health and of
course that process of cycling through
illness and wellness is very important
for all of us to go through in our lives
it makes us stronger and wiser and more
fit but at the same time I believe that
in conventional medicine and the concept
prevention is heavily underutilized
basically we control people's
cholesterol and give them backs teens to
interventions that I think are not the
full picture of prevention so let's talk
a little bit about how I believe that
cannabis can prevent disease and promote
health and some of the data that
supports this and we'll begin with a
really foundation of good health and
that's sleep but before I get to sleep
just a quick note about chronic disease
this is data from the CDC so half of all
adults in the United States have one or
more chronic health condition and 7 of
the 10 top causes of death are chronic
diseases arthritis is the leading cause
of disability and 86% of all healthcare
spending is for people with chronic
disease so imagine if we could chip away
at this chronic disease if we can not
only manage it but if we could prevent
it what kind of resources that would
free up and how much improvement in
quality of life and prevention of
suffering we could accomplish so let's
talk about sleep this is my son Sam
who's a great sleeper and so often you
hear people say oh I slept like a baby
and for my first two children I didn't
really understand that saying because
babies don't often sleep that well but
Sam is a champion sleeper as we can see
from this photo so how does sleep relate
to chronic disease basically I could
take a very healthy person and disturb
their sleep for a month and they come
down with a number of symptoms probably
pain and lack of concentration or focus
mood swings and and all sorts of other
things sleep is is so important now this
data from 2013 shows what the rates are
of some common conditions related to the
number of nights per month that
someone's getting adequate sleep or sort
of sleep or insufficient sleep and as
you can see here on the top left for
people that are sleeping poorly half the
night
four more so 14 to 30 days per month
with poor sleep they have a significant
increased rate in diabetes basically
either 35% more or 65% more likely to
have diabetes also for people that are
poor sleepers they have much higher
levels of coronary artery disease so 58
percent more coronary artery disease for
people that are sleeping poorly 14 to 29
nights per month and for people that
never sleep well more than double the
rate of coronary artery disease we see
similar numbers with stroke about 31%
more stroke in people with poor sleep
more than half the nights and for people
that sleep poorly every night more than
double the rate of stroke and same for
arthritis but even for people that sleep
poorly
1 to 13 nights per month they have a 26%
increased rate of arthritis and then as
you can see as sleep gets worse the rate
of arthritis just goes up and up now all
of these associations were still present
after adjusting for age sex race
education frequent mental distress and
obesity so these researchers were really
able to hone in and and show that
regardless of all these other factors
sleep is a risk factor for developing
all of these conditions and more non
restorative sleep is a strong
independent predictor of new onset
widespread pain in people that have non
restorative sleep or than half the
nights and much more likely to have
widespread pain and also sleep changes
how we respond to pain medications it
counteracts the analgesic effects of
opioid drugs and certain urging drugs so
these would be narcotic pain relievers
and antidepressants that can also help
with pain and it produces hyperalgesia
changes so poor sleep makes us more
sensitive to pain that's what Piper at
music changes means now if we look at a
report from the National Academies of
Sciences engineering and health and
medicine from the health and medicine
the vision in 2017 they did a very
comprehensive review on the data around
medical cannabis and adult use to
recreational or illicit use cannabis and
I'm just gonna show you a few of the
summary conclusions that they came up
with first of all they found conclusive
or substantial evidence that cannabis or
the compounds found in cannabis are
effective for the treatment of chronic
pain and adults for the treatment of
chemotherapy induced nausea and vomiting
and for improving multiple sclerosis
spasticity as is reported by the patient
they also found moderate evidence that
cannabis can be effective and improving
sleep outcomes in people with sleep
disturbance associated with a variety of
conditions sleep apnea fibromyalgia
chronic pain and multiple sclerosis so
I'm showing this to demonstrate that we
already have a good amount of data that
cannabis is an effective treatment for
sleep disturbance and it's not because
cannabis is a hypnotic it doesn't just
knock people out and make them fall
asleep what it ends up doing is
mitigating the symptoms that are
disturbing sleep in the first place so
this might be anxiety this might be pain
or depression or racing mental activity
inability to remain still restless limbs
and so forth there's lots of reasons why
people have disturbed sleep and it seems
like cannabis is able to help quite a
few of them so what are my strategies
for treating sleep disturbance with
cannabis well we can think about sleep
disturbance in kind of two parts there's
the onset of sleep so how fast does one
fall asleep at night or is it as a
person lying there awake for two hours
before they fall so and then there's
sleep maintenance so once a person falls
asleep are they waking up every hour
tossing and turning or do they stay
asleep in the morning for sleep onset
typically the best strategy with
cannabis that I found is the inhale
Brout and so that could be vaporization
or smoke if that's what somebody prefers
and of course using the right type of
cannabis so chemo var selection is very
important some
types of cannabis will be very awakening
and others will be more sedating so
choosing the sedating terpene profile or
sedating chemo bar is important now for
people that need help staying asleep
inhalation is not the best route because
it typically wears off after a few hours
and so you would want something with a
longer duration of action and that's why
oral delivery is going to be the best
taking a tincture and oil or a capsule
would be best I don't recommend edibles
I don't think it's a good idea to eat
right before bed while we sleep is a
good time for our digestive tract to
also stop digesting and to start
repairing and regenerating so I like to
allow it to do that while I was sleep
and avoid the edible now CBD is
interesting it's associated with
increased wakefulness and increased
total sleep time with less frequent
arousal that might seem a little
contradictory and based on my clinical
experience I believe I found that about
five or ten percent of my patients who
try using CBD in the night before bed it
actually keeps them awake most people
find that CBD makes them feel awake but
when they lay down and close their eyes
they're able to fall asleep no problem
and that 10% is really just a guess but
I think that's about what I'm seeing
also it's important to use cannabis as a
part of a healthy sleep hygiene routine
so if one is using cannabis
intentionally they can be dimming the
lights they can be avoiding screens and
all the other aspects of sleep hygiene
cannabis goes along with those well now
in my clinical practice I've seen
cannabis work for many conditions but I
believe that the symptom that I've seen
cannabis most effective for most
consistently effective for is
suppressing recall of nightmares in
people with post-traumatic stress
disorder
almost everyone with PTSD who have ever
seen that has sleep disturbed by
nightmares who ends up getting the right
dose of aural cannabis before bed
reports a significant improvement or a
complete improvement in their symptoms
and this is just a trial from 2009 they
use this in bed
cannabinoid nav alone and proved
basically that 60% of the patients
I had a total cessation of their
nightmares another 13% had a
satisfactory reduction so that was about
73% total responded to the synthetic
cannabinoid and their dose remains
stable over four to twelve months so
there wasn't dose escalation so very
effective and I think that herbal
cannabis can be more effective than a
synthetic cannabinoid now moving on from
sleep so some of the other conditions
that we start sleep disturbance
associated with like heart disease and
stroke so these are the leading causes
of death in the United States you can
just see how much heart disease there
are and there is in our country as well
as cancer and we'll talk about cancer a
little bit later in the talk
but let's start with heart disease the
leading cause of death so a great review
articles very concise from dr. Ethan
Russo in 2015 first of all looked at the
risks of cannabinoids and cardiovascular
disease can cannabis make cardiovascular
disease worse and what do we need to
know about it about using cannabis for
people that already have cardiovascular
disease is it safe for them to use
cannabis so stimulating cb1 receptor
particularly in someone who's new to
cannabis can increased heart rate and
increase blood pressure or decrease
blood pressure and low doses THC usually
stimulates the sympathetic to the
fight-or-flight nervous system and
inhibits the parasympathetic also known
as the rest and digest nervous system it
high doses we sometimes see the opposite
effect which can lead to orthostatic
hypotension basically blood pressure
goes down and someone gets dizzy after
they stand up as well as bradycardia
slow heart rate the acute effects of THC
including intoxication and tachycardia
often diminish with chronic
administration so people that are used
to cannabis have much less pronounced
cardiovascular side-effects people that
are new to cannabis may get a little bit
of a racing heart may get a little bit
of a low blood pressure for most people
this isn't going to be a big deal
if someone has very severe heart disease
say to the extent where they wouldn't be
able to safely walk up a flight of
stairs it also might not be safe for
them to use cannabis or it would only be
safe for them to use cannabis with very
precise careful dosing under medical
supervision nasty VD is an
anti-inflammatory antioxidant that tends
to counter the anxiety and tachycardia
side effects of THC that means
tachycardia is racing her and it also
appears to be broadly cardioprotective
which is a good reason to combine CBD
with THC in people that have
cardiovascular disease cardiovascular
side-effects what canvas are much more
common with inhale delivery like
especially with very potent forms of
inhalation smoking hash or dabs informal
studies of therapeutic administration
having a base of moles which is an oral
spray that contains equal parts CBD and
THC roughly a cardiovascular adverse
events were seen occasionally in their
early studies that have very high dosing
up to a hundred thirty milligrams of THC
per day but then the debates the most
trials changed their titration schedule
and made it a lot lower and slower
dosage slower to increase the dosage and
when they did that the cardiovascular
side-effects became extremely rare less
than two percent
incidents of tachycardia hypertension
and orthostatic hypotension so the dose
really makes the difference and so does
the delivery route inhaled cannabis
kicks in so quickly all at once that
you're more likely to get these
cardiovascular side effects oral
cannabis does not it kicks in a nice
gradual manner and and there's been it's
been shown that there's no QT interval
changes or related to that treatment now
we've just covered the risks of using
cannabis in people with heart disease or
cardiovascular disease what about the
potential benefits so what this diagram
explains is what we know about how
stimulating the cb2 receptor can have a
protective or a healing effect in two
situations heart attack and stroke which
are a similar types of conditions
something happens that occludes or
blocks the blood so
apply to a very important issue like the
heart muscle or the brain and that ends
up causing damage and that damage is
mediated by immune cells and by
inflammation and as you can see on the
slide here there's multiple mechanisms
of action by which the cb2 receptor r is
able to decrease the amount of damage
caused by these injuries and it does
that by acting on bascule or smooth
muscle on the endothelial cells on the
neutrophils this is one of the beautiful
things about the endocannabinoid system
is we see it all over the body all of
these different cell types express the
cb2 receptor and when we stimulate that
cb2 receptor with THC for example then
we're able to achieve these benefits at
least in preclinical models so here's an
example of a rodent study where mice
were these are mice that produce at
throw sclerotic lesions hardening of the
arteries and buildups of plaque and
basically after five weeks they were
given oral THC at a very modest dose one
milligram per kilogram per day and I can
see on the picture how the vehicle group
that did not receive the THC the size of
their lesions of their of the plaques
inside the arteries grew quite a bit
whereas the THC group only grew a little
bit over those next six weeks and so you
can see quite a difference there now
these researchers also administered a
cb2 blocker and that did and when they
administer THC with the blocker there
was no benefit so that shows the THC was
likely working via the cb2 receptor
another extremely interesting study from
2013
also in mice showed that administering a
tiny tiny dose of THC two hours before
inducing a heart attack protected the
heart and sped the recovery so the mice
that got this tiny dose of THC had
better fractional shortening that means
how well their heart was able to
contract after the injury they had less
troponin leakage troponin is a something
that the damaged heart cells will leak
garance way of measuring the damage they
had smaller infect size so the dead
cells were there were less of them was a
smaller area and less accumulation of
neutrophils to the infect area meaning
less immune activity less inflammation
there so it's just amazing that this
tiny dose of THC could do such a thing
and now I hope that most of you when
you're watching this are wondering well
what about me if I have a little bit of
THC in my system because this study in
my show that all you need is a tiny bit
if I have a little in my system could
that protect me from a heart attack and
I believe that we have some data now it
suggests the answer is yes so this study
from 2016 reviewed hospital records of
over a million patients in eight states
in almost 4,000 of them just
self-reported cannabis you-sun admission
now if you look at all the ones that had
a heart attack and you split them into
those that admitted to using cannabis
and those that said they don't use
cannabis and then control for some other
factors like everyone in the study was
under 70 years of age did not use
alcohol cocaine or meth amphetamines and
so forth and when we adjusted for some
of these other factors or when the
researchers did what they found was that
on the left side of the graph we have
the cannabis user to the right side we
have a non cannabis
oh excuse me on the left side of the
graph we have cannabis users
demonstrating a lower risk and on the
right side of the graph demonstrating a
higher risk and so you can see here that
the cannabis users had a lower overall
overall risk of death so this means out
of all these people that had a heart
attack if they were a cannabis user they
were less likely to die they were less
likely to need an intervention that's
like a balloon that's the IABP
they were less likely to go into shock
and they were less likely to need
another trend transcutaneous
intervention so less interventions and
less death the only thing that was worse
than the cannabis using group was a
higher likelihood of meeting a
ventilator which probably is because
most of these cannabis users were
smoking it and maybe that smoke was
irritating their lungs or causing
Titus or something like that another
similar study that looked at about three
and a half thousand patients in each so
of about seven thousand patients total
that were hospitalized for heart failure
and divided into cannabis users and non
cannabis users this study found that
among the heart failure patients the
cannabis users were much less likely to
develop a cardiac arrhythmia called
atrial fibrillation and and you can see
was about adjusted odds ratio was 0.87
so this means about 13% a lower
likelihood of having atrial fibrillation
and the cannabis users compared to the
nine users now heart attack and stroke
are similar condition stroke is also
very common one out of every 20 deaths
in the u.s. so that's on average every
four minutes someone's dying of a stroke
stroke cost the United States an
estimated thirty four billion dollars
each year and currently there are no
approved neuroprotective agents so what
do I mean that by that well when someone
has a stroke when there's an area of the
brain that dies because the blood supply
is disturbed there is a release of
contents from the dead cells and some of
those contents become toxic to the
surrounding cells especially something
called glutamate which creates an
excitotoxin e and then we see the
surrounding cells starting to get sick
and die they start releasing their
contents and we get this domino effect
it's called the stroke number and we
know that after someone has a stroke in
the next 48 to 72 hours the size of the
damage is going to grow and grow and
grow and basically we just sit there and
watch it happen because we don't have
any approved agents that can stop that
spread of damage and you can see on the
image on the left of how the ischemic
core in red will eventually spread to
the yellow area and then to the green
area so what can we do you know time is
brain some people say but that's well
they actually say it more with them with
heart attack because we do have
interventions that can help and so time
can be must
Kester we get that clot out of there
well the better someone is more likely
someone is to recover but we're not
we're not doing that very well with
stroke because we don't have a neuro
protective agent but what about
cannabinoids well we know from a lot of
animal research that first of all our
brain will make more cannabinoids when
it's injured inand amide and two AG are
endogenous neuroprotective agents
produced by the nervous system when it's
exposed to both chemical and mechanical
trauma and we know that these agents
along with THC CBD
and synthetic cannabinoids can all
decrease glutamate excitotoxicity which
can not only reduce seizure activity but
limit the size of the infarct after a
stroke this is well known and it has
been for a long time to the extent that
our United States Department of Health
and Human Services our federal
government owns a patent on the use of
cannabinoids as antioxidants and
neuroprotective agents and we can see in
this pan that there is a summary of the
literature suggesting that these
compounds
may be just the thing people should
receive when they have a stroke and we
have explored and elucidated many of the
mechanisms by how cannabis could protect
against stroke and there's it's more
than just Stevie - which I showed you on
an earlier slide cb1 receptors are
involved in protecting against glutamate
toxicity in preventing the excessive
release of glutamate whose T V 2
receptors we already talked about that
cannabinoids themselves are antioxidants
and can decrease reactive oxygen species
CBD works on the fight hg18 serotonin
receptor which can improve vascular
supply and and make it so the tissue is
less likely to die from starvation of
oxygen and then we have unknown targets
as well that that are still being
explored so many mechanisms for how
cannabinoids could potentially help
people with stroke now there's a huge
amount of animal data that cannabinoids
are protective in experimental models of
stroke and as you can see on the slide
here
whether it's endocannabinoids that are
tested THC or CBD there's been numerous
experiments and all of them showed that
the volume of the lesion is much smaller
when animals receive injections of these
compounds any cannabinoid whether it's
synthetic endocannabinoid meaning one
that the body produces or a phyto
cannabinoid like those found in the
plant cannabis have been associated with
less early motor impairment so less
damage that causes movement disorder
less late motor impairments and improve
survival and it's not just a little
improved survival it's more than double
the survival and the animals that
receive the cannabinoids an average and
this was a review article from 2014 of
all of this data does this data
translate to humans well yes it does
actually we have some observational
evidence not controlled clinical trials
but some suggestive evidence that people
who have brain injury that have cannabis
in their system are less likely to die
so this was a study from 2014 that
looked at four hundred and forty people
with traumatic brain injury their
overall death rate was nine point nine
percent when we divide them into people
with THC in their system or people
without THC in their system you can see
on the slide that the people with THC
were only 2.4 percent only 2.4 percent
of them died whereas 11.5 percent of
them teach t- group diet so again it
appears that cannabis is having a
protective effect at least it's
associated with less death another
studies from 2016 and 725 adult patients
with spontaneous brain believes again
show that cannabis positive number one
was much more likely to have no symptoms
so if you look at these at the top line
on the bar graph is kinetically positive
and the bottom this can have my negative
and so you can see 19 percent of the
cannabis group cannabis users had no
symptoms after their brain bleed while
only 3 percent of the non cannabis group
was symptom free and you can see that
whole shift to the right of the
this group all the way to death 26
percent of the cannabis group died while
33 percent in the non-campus group died
there's also a significant amount of
research by using CBD to protect against
perinatal brain injuries so this would
be lack of oxygen due to birthing and a
newborn rats and pigs the CBD has been
shown to reduce the death of the neurons
and the astrocytes which are like immune
cells in the brain to preserve brain
activity prevent increased biomarkers of
brain damage prevent the appearance of
seizures and improve the performance
neurobehavioral performance when
examined 72 hours later and several
weeks later so this is likely very
protective in that studying now let's
change gears from heart attack and
stroke to another leading cause of death
and certainly a disability and suffering
cancer I here are the types of cancer
that are most common in the United
States we have 230 thousand new cases of
breast cancer every year and 40 women
die of it every year and you can see the
rest of this statistics it looks like
people are dying more of lung cancer
than of other types of cancer but our
our rates of cancer are so high for a
number of factors we don't have time to
discuss in this presentation but
basically for someone living in the
United States if you're a man your risk
of developing a nan skin cancer so an
invasive cancer is about one in two in
your lifetime and your risk of dying
from a cancer is about one in four if
you're a woman it's a little bit better
your risk of developing an invasive
cancer is one in three and your risk of
dying from it is one in five but cancer
is a big deal and so if we're talking
about preventing disease this is one
that I think we should talk about
preventing and and so same with stroke
and same with heart disease and again I
want to circle back some of where we
started today with just sleep because I
think sleep has an impact on everything
that we talked about in today's lecture
so at one point I was very interested in
finding the study
and the animals who had been exposed to
the highest dose of cannabis or THC for
the longest period of time to see how
sick these animals could be from a huge
dose and so I found the national
toxicology program report from 1996
where rats were given THC either a
placebo or just a vehicle carrier by
12.5 milligrams per kilogram which is a
pretty high ghost 25 milligrams per
kilogram or 50 milligrams per kilogram
which is an extremely high dose in corn
oil for two straight years and the
researchers said that survival of all
dosed groups was generally significantly
greater than the controls this means
that the 12 and a half the 25 and the 50
milligram per kilogram group was more
likely to survive than the placebo or
the control group the dosed animals had
decreased incidence of mammary
fibroadenoma so that's breast cancer
uterine polyps pituitary adenoma
testicle adenoma and in creati care
anomalies these ones hitting huge doses
of THC developed less cancer
there was no increased incidence of any
cancer type in the dosed animals and the
animals that receive the Chiefs knee had
a lower mean body weight seems like
pretty good results at very high doses
there is some human evidence also that
shows that people who smoke a lot of
joints compared to people who don't use
any cannabis do not have an increased
rate of respiratory tract cancers and
that's probably surprising because
smoking a lot of joints exposes one to
numerous carcinogens not that
cannabinoids themselves but the products
of combustion like the tars and other
other carcinogens that are in this smoke
so even though they're getting exposed
to that smoke they don't have any higher
rate of cancers and this data was non
significant but it shows that maybe a
little hint that the cannabis users have
a lower rate of lung cancer or there
might be a trend in the direction of
less lung cancer in the cannabis users
despite their exposure to so many
carcinogens why probably because the can
is exerting an anti-cancer effect and
balances out the effect of those
carcinogens cannabis used was associated
with a much lower rate of bladder cancer
in men and this was a large study in
2015 from the California men's health
database cannabis users had 45% less
bladder cancer while tobacco users had
52% more
bladder cancer and again most of these
cannabis users were probably smoking and
so cannabis is having some type of a
protective effect here I was also
curious and I scoured the literature for
possibilities of how cannabis could
cause cancer is it possible because
cannabis is so often a double-edged
sword like most things that are and if
we used it appropriately maybe it could
be helping and if inappropriately maybe
it could be hurting and so I did find
that there is an increased rate of
testicular cancer in men who are
cannabis users three studies have shown
this a total of 719 cases compared to
1400 controls and what they found was
that for people that were high frequency
cannabis users about a 56% increased
rate of testicular cancer and for people
that were using cannabis for ten years
and more about a 50% increased risk and
so testicular cancer generally occurs in
young men not always and my assumption
even though the data didn't describe any
of this so these are young men who are
probably using canvas for the purpose of
getting high or experiencing before eeeh
and probably using a lot of it very
frequently now numerous preclinical or
animal studies have shown that cannabis
has anti-cancer effects and these
mechanisms of action have been
elucidated if you look at this list on
the slide there's just so many types of
cancers that have been shown to respond
to canvas more and more all the time and
just like a stroke and the heart attack
conversation there's not a single
mechanism of action cannabis is working
with fight cancer in many ways including
triggering programs
and that's like an intelligent recycling
of the cancer cell increasing apoptosis
and regime which is like a cellular
cleanup suppressing tumor angiogenesis
which means preventing the blood vessels
from growing that beat tumors inhibiting
the ability for the camp of the cancer
to adhere to and migrate through tissue
which allows for metastasis throughout
the body and it's also important to
point out that the cannabinoids are able
to do all of these things to help
prevent and fight cancer without hurting
healthy cells and that's always the goal
when it comes to cancer treatments how
can we harm the cancer without harming
the individual now we are all developing
cancerous cells all the time a cell is
supposed to die we'll have a problem in
its cell cycle a little mutation or a
breakdown of the normal process that
causes that cell to die and it suddenly
starts growing instead of dying and
maybe multiplying and then very quickly
our bodies have many making up
mechanisms for identifying that and
nipping it in the bud it's when we fail
to do so that eventually those cells
would grow into a tumor and then
eventually potentially grow into a
cancer that spreads throughout the body
and so what can we do to support our
innate mechanism that's always at work
always trying to help us fight cancer
that's constantly happening well I think
cannabinoids are a good choice because
they're so safe for healthy cells no one
would want to take chemotherapy by just
for prevention in hopes that they're not
gonna get cancer who couldn't do that
because the side effects are way too
severe but something that's safe like
cannabis that's part of an anti-cancer
strategy here's just some examples of
what we see in the literature so on the
Left we see the rate of growth of breast
cancers tumors basically these are human
cancer cell lines that are injected into
rodents and then the rodents are exposed
to different conditions and researchers
watch how fast those tumors grow and so
you can see the rate of growth in the
control group on the left and then when
you look at the group that received
caves seeing their tumors still grew but
grew much
slowly and then we see similar results
with a synthetic cannabinoid that acts
like THC and another study that I think
is very interesting shows how cannabis
at least in this case to have with a
certain chemotherapy agent called
temozolomide in a setting of glioma
which is type of brain cancer and this
is or THC is the able to enhance the
effects of Gemma's Olamide so you can
see the rate of growth over 15 days
vehicle at top of the slide the next
line down is THC so chains beyond its
own didn't decrease the rate of growth
of his cancer Tenma's Olamide decrease
the rate of growth a little bit more but
look at that part of mine look at the
combination of THC and this chemotherapy
agents just remarkable and there's been
subsequent studies that have looked at
combination of CBD and THC
and that study showed that both are
effective especially when combined the
various ratios but interestingly not CBD
fine and strong CBD plus the Missoula
mine did not perform as well as TVD
Batian is as temozolomide on its own but
that's just one animal study so also
besides enhancing the effects of
chemotherapy cannabis has been shown to
enhance the effects of radiation therapy
and you can see again the rate of the
growth of this type of brain cancer
glioma over 21 days on the top left you
can see the untreated animals the top
right treated with cannabinoids and this
was a combination of CBD and THC the
bottom left shows the radiation therapy
so none of those results were very
impressive but look at the bottom right
the combination of radiation and
cannabinoids super impressive there was
almost no growth and that's summarized
in in Section C on the right you can see
how radiation plus can actually
outperform all the other interventions
now we hear about cases of people with
cancer that have decided not to use
chemotherapy or radiation or any
conventional treatment and they decide
just to use cannabis sometimes very
high dose handlers and sometimes they
get great results we actually only hear
about the cases typically we get great
results all the cases where it doesn't
work usually don't make it to case
reports and to the internet but here was
one case published in o'Shaughnessy's
Journal of cannabis and clinical
practice in 2013 where we have an infant
or toddler I believe I think two years
old that had an invasive optic pathway
glioma it was not operable it wasn't
likely that any radiation or
chemotherapy would be successful in
killing the cancer it might have just
extended life a little bit so the
parents opted not to go that route they
took the baby home and started putting
cannabis oil on its pacifier and you can
see from August 2011 to December 2012
the reduction in that big white mass in
the middle of the brain and it totally
went away as far as I understand this
person is still alive today there was a
little human data that was released in
the press release but not in a
publication yet I expect they'll be
coming out at some point
but this was a placebo controlled
clinical study of a low to moderate dose
of the victim all that oral sprays
Indian TV in people with a very
aggressive brain tumor glioblastoma
multiforme and the one-year survival
rate and in the midst of all this group
was 83 percent but in the control group
was only 53 percent so at one year this
was showing very promising results and
it's so well tolerated and it helps with
quality of life it helps with mood and
pain and sleep and all of this it just
makes so much sense for people with
cancer especially this type of cancer to
be using it but again I'm talking about
preventing cancer so when you see
results like this they giving this low
dose of cannabis along with conventional
treatment can really increase the rate
of survival and people that already have
a cancer what could it do in people and
don't have a cancer but might be a risk
for one based on a variety
genetic and environmental factors let's
turn the page and look at obesity and
diabetes
so a really an alarming problem now in
the United States and very sadly the
United States has exported its dietary
habits to the rest of the world
so you can see that I think the colors
and pictures on the map speak for
themselves but the rates of obesity
increase drastically over the last 2025
years the idea is again also increasing
drastically the medical cost of obesity
in the United States in 2008 was a
hundred and forty seven billion the
medical cost of diabetes 176 billion I'd
like to put that number into perspective
so in 2008 the UN did a study about what
it would cost to feed the entire nation
the entire world excuse me what would be
the cost of preventing all famine and
hunger and the price tag they put on
that was 30 billion dollars per year and
they also said that if we did that for
ten years in a row spent that much money
on eradicating hunger then we would have
a sustainable infrastructure it would
prevent hunger in future look at how
much we're spending on disease
associated with eating too much bad food
being the wrong food eating too much of
it and and what if we could just shift a
little bit of that to helping all the
people that are hungry and starving I
also like to put this into perspective
with the u.s. annual defense budget in
2015 is six hundred billion dollars what
if we took some of that defense budget
and made it one of our main missions to
feed the people that are hungry things
like that might actually help keep our
world and our country safe and decrease
crime and decrease all sorts of aberrant
behavior we spend a lot of money on
things other than fighting hunger but
actually let's get back to the point
what about cannibals so cannabis used
been associated in numerous large
studies with a lower incidence of
obesity so for example in one study non
cannabis users had 22% rate of obesity
cannabis users more than three times a
week
a 14% rate of obesity and you can see
similar results from a subsequent study
and this has been this has been
evaluated several times and always looks
around these numbers
same thing with diabetes people with
recent use of canvas for 40% less likely
to be diabetic and nine users none of
these studies on a determined causation
we can't say that the reason they're not
developing diabetes is because they're
using cannabis
maybe the reason they're not developing
diabetes is because they love dancing
and they're very active and that's the
same reason they love using cannabis
because they enjoy it well I mean you
know there's many potential explaining
explanation so you can't say that in
humans it's been creaming the cannabis
prevents diabetes and obesity but we do
have some very suggest some suggestive
evidence from animal studies that it can
do exactly that so this wasn't my study
in which tht was administered to two
groups of mice those that were fed a
diet that's known to keep them lean and
those fed a diet that's known to induce
obesity and when you can see let's we
can look at the Left column first we
have the first row is body weight change
the second row fatness change in the
third row daily energy intake and you
can see that in on the left side whether
the mice got THC or whether they got a
control didn't really make a difference
they all basically ended up the same so
basically in the diet that keeps
mysoline THC did not make them fat it
did not make them extra lean it just
really didn't do much at all but if we
look at the right side of this chart in
madera and the top right we can see the
dark squares are the the mice that were
fed the obesity inducing diet and
receive change see in the white squares
they did not receive you see and look at
the difference there in the
body weight moving down to letter G look
at the difference in their fat mass and
down at the bottom the difference in
their energy intake was pretty modest so
what's really interesting is that it
wasn't necessarily that the THC fed mice
were eating less it looks like they were
eating a little bit less but not that
much fuss but their their fat and their
body weight were much less really
interesting now these researchers also
took a look at the bacteria in the guts
of these mice and what they found was
that my students in th think that were
fed the obesity diet they get changes in
their bacterial populations that we know
are associated with obesity mice to
receive the change see not only did they
remain mean they did not have those
bacterial changes so potentially one of
the mechanisms of action isn't it is you
know not just acting on our metabolism
but also acting on the bacteria in the
gut and promoting a healthy range of
bacterial life so we've covered a lot
we've covered sleep heart attack and
stroke obesity diabetes cancer now a lot
of people are wondering how do we put
this into action and I and I just want
to bring some attention to the
psychoactive effects of cannabis because
when we're talking about preventive
medicine
I believe it's dress production needs to
be an important focus like this as an
indication that almost every disease
state and more and more as people are
coming to cannabis they want to
experience the benefits of cannabis on
their symptoms they want to feel less
pain they want to sleep better they want
to have less anxiety will better focus
more alertness whatever it is those
things are all great and I still believe
that one of the primary healing effects
of cannabis has to do with its capacity
to shift our tranches to change the way
that we perceive and relate to our
environment and I want to emphasize that
because
more and more I have patients that come
to me and they say I want any music
cannabis but I never want to get high
and you do that for me doc and I say
yeah we can do that and then I'm the
follow-up visit you know Angela
mentioned well you mate you know this
thing that you called getting high it's
really not that intense and may benefit
you in some ways and this is what I tell
them about you know first of all you
Toria which is commonly reported as a
side-effect of cannabis is actually in
my opinion typically a side benefit
especially when it's controllable and
then happening at the right place to the
right time it's a way to phoria positive
mood relaxation laughter more
socializing a distortion of time which
can be very helpful for people that are
so caught up in the future and caught up
in the past and missing out on a present
moment and the intensification of
ordinary experiences so things like
eating listening music watching TV or
films having sex these things can become
more enjoyable when one is experiencing
the Cannabis state of consciousness does
that seem like a bad thing to me that
seems like it would just enhance quality
of life and reduce stress these are some
of the other things that patients were
kidding
tummy about one days to finally do
experience how cannabis can shape their
consciousness they describe an increased
self-awareness and unbundling of
symptoms and suffering that's my term
but what people generally say is let me
put it this way most people that are
experiencing pain they they they just
come in and they say this is hurting me
I'm having pain and that's it's like one
single experience after using cannabis
people start to realize oh there's a
sensation that I'm feeling and then
there's a part of me that judges that
sensation is bad and then there's a part
of me that doesn't want to have that
sensation anymore and gets anxious about
it and there's anxious all the time
about it and then there's the army that
acts on that anxiety and that and that
that behavior then starts affecting my
family and my relationships and so forth
and they're able is separated all out
which is really helpful that unbundling
really suffering right there and and
cannabis repeatedly does that for my
patients they say well the pain is less
intense but more even more than that
it's it's a different experience now
it's just more like a sensation and I
can leave it there I don't have to get
upset about it I don't get anxious about
it and I don't have to let it bother me
if I choose not to moving on
people frequently report that the
cannabis state of consciousness helps
them feel a connection to something
greater than themselves whether it's the
universe or God on each it helps them
view one's self from a different vantage
point it fosters acceptance to things in
life I do this all the time that people
find they accept their illness except
their chapter in life well maybe they're
disabled or have different abilities
helps people find creative solutions for
their problems and it promotes
flexibility flexibility of the mind
emotional flexibility literally physical
flexibility and capacity to change so I
think when people experience this they
can you have a very healing effect
especially when it's at the right dose
and that would be the right dose of THC
in the right index supportive
environment okay so let's talk about
ways that we can influence the
endocannabinoids system without using
canvas now bring it all back together
and we can tie it up because a lot of
what I'm talking about tonight about
using cannabis to prevent disease is
based on something that we're already
doing
we all have an endocannabinoid system
we're all producing molecules that
function a lot like THC for the purpose
of preventing disease and responding to
illness and injury in a way that
prevents those problems from becoming
chronic just like I told you about with
the brain injury right when we get a
brain injury our brain starts making
cannabinoids it's enough for a
protective reason and so adding some
additional genomics from outside might
make sense so really everything we've
talked about here is new at the function
of the endocannabinoid system and
cannabis is clearly not the only thing
that affects that function so let's talk
about one dietary
yes but polyunsaturated fatty acids so
these are fatty acids that are known as
essential nutrients meaning we don't
make them in our body we have to consume
them in our diet and our body needs them
as building blocks for signaling
messenger molecules so omega-3 and
omega-6 is and a hot topic for decades
now and rightfully so it plays a large
influence on our health so an imbalance
of omega-6 to omega-3 ratio is linked to
several neurologic in neuropsychiatric
disorders Ananda my are under
cannabinoid including another
endocannabinoid are derived directly
from arachidonic acid which is no mega 6
fatty acid we have other
endocannabinoids arrived from omega-3
fatty acids so these fatty acids are the
building blocks of our endocannabinoids
if we don't have enough of them it's
gonna be hard for us until end of 10
points at the right levels omega-3
supplementation or a diet rich in
omega-3 is has been shown to induce
physical pain significantly the dietary
intervention for omega-3 blessing and
that less pain has been correlated to an
increased level of the endocannabinoids
that are produced from these omega-3
fatty acids DHEA and this setting is
that the androgen hormone DHEA with
those actually are and then look at
annoyed as every issue 88 so in summary
dietary polyunsaturated fatty acid
intake alters our endocannabinoid system
omega-3 consumption and reduce inanimate
and 2ag levels that may actually be
causing singing 1 desensitization such
as that case of obesity and so I wanna I
want to put this out there right now a
lot of times we get very black-and-white
think about the endocannabinoid system
like more is better more and those
nominees equals better health and of
course that's way too oversimplified in
certain areas of adding more is better
and others probably less is better in
certain physiologic conditions
so for example people with obesity often
have much higher levels of
endocannabinoids to the extent that
they're likely desensitizing their
endocannabinoid system it's just like
when someone goes tolerance to THC this
is building power into our own
endocannabinoids and that just regulates
the system and one of the ways to get
the system back online is to actually
gently black endocannabinoid receptors
black I see one receptor and we can do
that with THC surprising because THC is
a partial agonist which means in most
settings it's going to be stimulating
the city one receptor but when this
thing when the receptors are over
stimulated already THC can actually
block it just a little bit and allow it
to return to its normal function that
was a long tangent but an important one
omega-3 consumption in increased DHEA
and 2g which may have anti pinging and
other benefits via the end of Cameron
system how do I recommend people get
this in their diet and this plan also
provides some seeds a great source of
both omega-3 and omega-6 fatty acids
along with essential amino acids it's
really quite a complete food highly
recommend including foods in the diet
and then small Coldwater fish like
sardines and krill which we typically
don't need but are whales too and for
people that aren't just totally in love
with sardines or other things like wild
salmon and apples full of krill oil or
high quality fish oil could be a good
solution for people that want to
supplement their diet okay let's talk
about some other plans for the system
beta carry a sling is a terpene it's
found not only in cannabis but also in
black pepper lemon balm clothes and
quite a bit of it from South America
called beta carotene has been shown to
be a full agonist at the cb2 receptor
which provides anti-inflammatory anti
scarring or inter fibrotic anti itch and
other than
and remember was that singing super
sector activity that protected that was
part of the protective mechanism in
stroke and in heart attacks so beta
carry a clean theoretically for the
outdoor in those settings echinacea is a
nerve with a new modulating effects has
been used for a long time it can change
our minds that are also active at the c2
receptor as well as other targets that
keep our gamma receptor which is a
nuclear transcription as well as partial
or inverse agonist effects of the cb1
receptor there's also a dietary sources
of inhibitors of the enzyme if a fatty
acid amide hydrolyze something this is
the enzyme that breaks down our
endocannabinoids an animai and sophiana
the enzyme and up with higher levels of
an ammonite which could be good in
certain situations and these are all
foods that are considered adaptogens on
healthy foods so galangal is a food it's
kind of like ginger it's found in some
Thai food maca is another root thought
of as tonic an expert in here and then
most of us are familiar with our
chocolate compounds that can inhibit in
increased levels of endocannabinoids I
mentioned beneficial bacteria and we've
got earlier of probiotics and maybe a
lacto-fermentation have been shown to
have a beneficial effect on the
endocannabinoids system so in human
epithelial cells exposing them to
there's one type of likely still as has
been shown to increase the expression of
the genes that build like two receptor
and also increased pain in rats and that
decrease in pain was blocked by cb2
receptor so it looks like the probiotics
lactobacillus acidophilus has something
to do with our cv2 activity at least in
the gut maybe elsewhere in the body
Lamar
article from 2014 from John McFarlane
co-parenting and the cannabinoid system
also covered many of the influences I'm
around the cannabinoid system other than
cannabis stress and social play are
really big words so chronic stress
impairs the end of family system being
decreased levels of a nanite including
gene social play and rads increases any
one correlation this is a marker of how
active seen one is in the amygdala and
in and against inanimate levels and you
nicola and nucleus accumbens so we
probably don't need money to tell us but
play is a good thing and stress and
chronic stress i should say is a bad
thing because most of us currently plug
one and dislike the other but it's
another reminder of how we can affect
our end of the immune system these are
basics of health but we know that it's
working via the end of them like them or
not
we know that less chronic stress and
more play can be good things exercise
medium to high intensity voluntary
exercise increases and dopamine
signaling the increase arminana my
levels and possibly increased cb1
receptor expression force to exercise
did not increase the enemy levels and it
has been shown to decrease thinking one
expression now these experiments are
done in rodents and we can actually
force the road in Tehran in a wheel or
we can allow it to run on a wheel
voluntarily and you can see that the
same activity has a different effect
based on whether voluntary or force now
I doubt that rodents are going to force
themselves to exercise but unfortunately
I think that people do and so one of my
take-home messages that if you're
exercising regularly make sure that you
enjoy it because if you eat it your
body's probably seen as a form of
chronic stress and it's probably not
helping find something they do love now
exercise has been shown appealing to
increased anonymize levels not just in
animals but also and so you can see here
that the levels of an animai
entry significantly after 30 minutes of
treadmill run and the increasing
anonymized was correlated with
increasing and improvement in mood so
those that had the best mood after
exercise also had the highest level of
anonymity after exercise a lot of what
we think about the runner's high which
can use their English is an endorphin or
our endogenous oiling system working is
also related to endocannabinoids
exercise I was absolutely in part
mediated by a new cameras now bodywork
has also been shown to increase levels
of mental cameras and any of you that
have had good bodywork this study was
asking nothing manipulation but I expect
that other cuts of bodywork do the same
thing after the treatment there's quite
a euphoric feeling
people often described as being floating
or getting or just feeling super relaxed
and calm and content those are the types
of good feelings that we experience with
increased levels of endocannabinoids and
ethnic relation is of course one of my
favorites because I'm in a state captain
this is a type of treatment that I
perform on most of my patients excellent
results and no cannabinoid regulation
and following thermogenic activation
maybe these kinds of many of you haven't
heard about this is something that's
actually come being big in my life so we
can think about all the different
helping to prevent disease you can
exercise and sleep these are all very
important there's something in this
world that we can use to promote health
that we know a lot about but a lot of
people don't use and that is temperature
or heat and cold energy so a thermal
thermal therapy because you know being
exposed to the heat maybe it's a sauna
like eating again you know bath I'm also
being exposed to cold maybe it's nice
after an injury or maybe it's an ice
bath or cold shower outside in the
winter these are all things they can
really
our physiology and at the right dose
promote market improvements in health
and so for example winter swimmers have
less cardiovascular disease and less
colds includes people that use scarlet
three times a day or more have longer
lifespans less cancer less pretty
vascular disease the exposure to these
chebyshev streams can be quite healthy
when done correctly so this was an
animal study in 2016 that showed that
exposure to cold causing an upregulation
of endocannabinoids Lovells and the
biosynthetic enzymes of 15-cent of
nanites in white adipose tissue white
adipose tissue is our normal body fat
well that we think of as normal it's
what most people have for that issue
it's white and the reason it's white and
that brown is because it doesn't have
mitochondria now many mitochondria are
the energy production machines that live
inside the cell it's the same reason
that when you eat chicken meat or when
someone is checking me there's a white
meat and dark meat is dark because it's
full of mitochondria and we find it in
the legs because chickens are using
those muscles all the time they're going
to run and so therefore those muscles
require a lot of energy production
whereas the white meat doesn't require
as much they're not flying
and so activation of brown adipose
tissue and browning of the white adipose
tissue in mice causes upregulation of
endocannabinoid levels and presumably
and no cannabinoid signaling via the cb1
receptor and I just kept thinking shout
out to women if we always choose comfort
we never learned the deepest
capabilities of our mind or body is a
record holder that's an incredible
technique that combines many types of
stress and allows one to more
comfortably experience fully exposure
and achieve its benefits which is taking
three online there's a free app and I
tried to set almost every day it's
brought a huge amount of benefits within
my
so I encourage people to check it out as
a way to stay healthy and also as a
treatment for pain again for depression
moving on from Coley's pose here another
one of my favorites that a lot of people
don't necessarily like right at the
beginning this bastard
passing has been shown to increased
levels of Ananda my dad sweetie
in certain areas of the brain and that
hypothalamic to a gene in crimes as
animals eat so when we're in a fasted
state we're making more and again it's
totally free or we think of it is the
opposite of expensive because it saves
people money it's something any of us
can do any time with a little research
and guidance for supervision this best
you can be extremely safe effective way
to promote health and you know that just
one of the ways that might Motel frisbee
alignment system so let's wrap it up in
summary my recommendations for
cannabinoid system
panting activities like a three fatty
acids like um sting sardines and so
forth bathing area cleaning the
fermented foods reducing stress
improving social play
enjoying the exercise that you're doing
daily or almost every day checking out
manual medicine like treatment as well
as energy medicine
ice bathing in particular if you prepare
yourself using the one cost method and
fasting now that's all the things beyond
canvas that we can do to enhance our
endocrine system the next question is
what can you do to use canvas to prevent
disease and promote health these are
some of my recommendations number one
these animals in a way that our bodies
tolerance building if you feel tolerance
to cannabis then you can also build our
ins to your downregulated your endocrine
system
so always lowest effective
those to achieve your goal now what are
your goals well you know should be
number one excellent restorative sleep
if you're not getting great sleep on a
regular basis you're at risk for all
these diseases so use cannabis to come
over sort of seeking ways that we've
described theory would do that
how else could I use canvas to prevent
disease and promote health improve
social play get creative have fun more
often and reduce stress and I think
animals can absolutely do that at a low
dose you don't have to be stoned you
don't have to be loose nating just a
little bit can go a long way in the
right environment with the right
expectation now use cannabis to promote
physical activity a lot of people find
it just a little bit of enemas before
yoga before going for a run for any type
of exercise another one of my favorites
is bouncing around on a champion you get
a great workout cannabis enhance
enjoyment and take people deeper into
their practice of exercise as well as
other practices like meditation in
prayer and we didn't cover that in
today's talk but things like gratitude
just counting their blessings spending
time meditating being mindful or
connecting to whatever we consider a
higher power all those things are
associated with reduce stress and less
chronic disease finally someone might
ask well how can I use cannabis in a way
where it's not going to cause like a
different feeling in me but might still
act as a tonic healthy one of my
favorite ways to do this and probably
the best way to do so is cannabis team
so you can literally just take up a
sized piece of rock cannabis flower can
be dry
you pour hot water over and let it steep
for five minutes and drink the tea and
if you're willing to eat that little bit
of flower that's left in the color
that's going to have very low levels of
THC in it
most of the memories that are present
the thta and it's for acid and the acid
form is the raw form of the cannabis
among the chemist opinion this teach the
interns
see the CBA turns into CV and so forth
so when you drink on the team yes you
will get a little change - it's right
over mostly gonna be getting that sick
never nice
we have powerful anti-inflammatory
properties and I don't want to discount
these tiny amounts of TV as he saw a
super small amount of TV was enough to
prevent the damage some of the damage of
a heart attack and that mouse model so
that summarizes how I recommend to
promote health and prevent disease and
of course when it comes to my
interactions with an individual we're
not one I really do my best to identify
what are their weak spots in their in
their health promotion disease
prevention specific target that ask
yourself the same questions and probably
get some good answers
I hope this was helpful for you thank
you so much please feel free to check
out helia calm it's my patient education
website it's free a lot of this
information a lot of other information
about how to use cannabis safely and
about side effects you can find it all
there and thank you so much thank you
dr. Sulak for that informative
presentation I would also like to thank
LaRue --ts for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that this
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing from June 28th 2019 as a final
reminder our speaker will follow up with
any questions you've submitted via email
dr. Sulak will do his best to answer
questions in a timely manner always
trying to triage more urgent patient
care demands from his practice attendees
who feel like they would benefit from
more education and would like to
schedule one-on-one time speaking with
dr. Sulak can schedule an appointment
through his office just log on to healer
calm to do so that is all for now thank
you for joining us we will see you next
time goodbye